[Musik]
die schönsten ist
es ist so
[Musik]
ja
hey leute heute machen wir ein süßes
ramadan rezept und damit heiße ich euch
herzlich willkommen zu kikis ramadan
es ist zwar nicht als allererste rezept
meiner diesjährigen ramadan reihe aber
das erste süße rezept wir machen den
chargers wer jetzt denkt ihr euch ist
doch einen scherzhaften nein es geht
auch süß und las berät ist richtig süden
richtig lecker müssen perfekt wenn man
abends nach möchte noch so ein bisschen
süß möchte und ich zeige euch mal ganz
besondere zutat jetzt nicht auf die
theke gepasst hat weil sie einfach zu
lang ist und zwar ist das schiff
charakterrolle kafka das ist viel
der ist hauchdünn und den gibt es fertig
zu kaufen und davon brauchen wir eine
packung und jetzt gewinner und ich zeige
euch die restlichen zutaten für den
kunden benötigen wir milch mehl
speisestärke außerdem zucker 1 1
butter und vanille extrakt und zum
bestreichen der teig wetter benötigen
wir sonnenblumenöl und butter und für
den zuckersirup wasser zitronensaft und
natürlich zu können sonst stehe ich hier
am herd und bereitet zuallererst im
pudding zu dafür nimmt euch ganz einfach
einen ausreichend großen topf und gibt
alle zutaten die ich für den pudding
genannt haben
bis auf die butter und den herd noch
nicht einschalten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und als nächstes verrät ihr das mit dem
schneebesen richtig schön klümpchen
breit und dann wird der herd
eingeschaltet
[Musik]
der probleme ist auch sofort ein gedeck
wir sehen könnt und wichtig ist eben
ständig rühren und sobald es ein liegt
im herbst fort ausschalten
jetzt müssen wir für die konsistenz noch
unsere butter hinzugeben und da der
pudding sehr heiß ist schmeckt es auch
sofort also einfach nur noch ein rühren
[Musik]
den pudding im film wird einmal um in
eine schüssel und der muss jetzt 20
minuten lang auskühlen was sie aber
unbedingt vorher machen müsst ist das
ganze eine oberfläche zu es einfach so
sagen gefallen also das ganze eine
oberfläche einmal mit frischhaltefolie
abdecken dann wie gesagt 20 minuten
stehen lassen aber in der zwischenzeit
machen wir weiter mit dem vorteil
[Musik]
so jetzt geht es weiter um unseren
böckler partei der er eigentlich erst
mal sehr dünn und sehr trocken ist um
ihn gleich zu trinken brauchen wir eine
mischung aus öl und butter und das habe
ich hier schon vorbereitet also die
butter ganz einfach in der mikrowelle
geschmolzen
es gebe ich jetzt zusammen mit dem
öldruck mit dem schlüssel und dann fahre
ich das
[Musik]
so dass butter öl gemisch das kommt
jetzt ganz süß an die seite und wir
kümmern uns um den teig der teig da
kommt immer in einer rechteckigen form
ich habe euch das rezept auch instagram
schon mal gezeigt auch in einer
rechteckigen backform aber häufig ist
was ganz besonderes heute nehme ich
meine eigene evaluierte backform eine
runde
hier seht ihr mögliches logo und das
welches überlebt es heißt ihr könnt
darauf kratzen drauf schneiden da
passiert gar nichts und da wir ja später
auch drauf schneiden müssen ist dass
gerade heute perfekt und dann geht es
einfach drauf auf mein tag und schneide
mir da nichts runde platten damit
zurecht
[Musik]
habt ihr euch ja zurecht geschnitten
das heißt wir haben hier einmal unsere
rundenzeit blätter und wir haben unseren
verschnitt und den durch die nicht
wegwerfen den werde ich jetzt gleich
ganz einfach dazwischen mogeln das
verwenden wir heute alles und wir
starten jetzt damit indem wir unser
butter gemischt und die backform damit
zuallererst mal einfetten und dann
können geschichten
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr gesehen dass sich das
geschichte ab und zu habe ich hier mal
ein bundestag blatt genommen und immer
butter irre mich drüber gestrichen also
immer weil jeder schicht bis auf jetzt
da muss es nicht unbedingt sein jetzt
habe ich hier noch die letzte schicht
kilo teig drauf gegeben und die hälfte
der viele teig wetter sind aufgebraucht
und jetzt ist der moment wo der pudding
rüberkommen der konnte in der
zwischenzeit zirka 20 minuten 1 ab
frieden ist aber auf jeden fall noch
lauwarmen der muss jetzt auch nicht
vollständig abkühlen wichtig war nur
dass wir den mich halt drauf geben
und jetzt den kompletten pudding darauf
verteilen und glatt streichen
also das video wieder vor gedreht
eigentlich ja und uneigentlich nicht
weil wir gleich zu den eltern gehen und
das dann mit bevor wir geld bekommen
sagen warum
nein sie haben mir jetzt einige videos
vorgedreht drei bis vier und den rest
den drehen wir dann wäre damals
das habe ich hier noch mal mit der
winkel palette glatt gestrichen
und als nächstes meine lieben ich bin
ich eigentlich nicht so weiter machen
sind einfach schon mal bedrückt als
nächstes geben wie die restlichen viel
besser drauf und verfahren immer so
weiter auch vor allem mit dem öl gemisch
immer so weiter bis die komplett
aufgebraucht sind
[Musik]
so mein letzter teig gebe ich jetzt noch
da drüber so und jetzt sind wir quasi
fertig es fehlt jetzt nur noch die
oberste schicht entweder gibt jetzt noch
so den rest von eurem butter öl gemisch
darüber das wäre kein problem aber ich
habe ein pro tipp für euch unser butter
gehen ich habe euch das letztes jahr
während der raman reihe da habe ich doch
dass baklava rezept da habe ich euch
meine mutter erzählt ich glaube einige
erinnern sich noch
es ist ein richtiger pro tipp die ganzen
syrischen konditoren die benutzten
motegi und aber wirklich nur ein
bisschen obendrüber nicht zu viel und
ich mache das jetzt so weil es geht
nochmal so richtig schönes aroma und ich
mach das jetzt so dass ich mir so ein
kleines bisschen nehme
gebt mir das zur 1 ganz kurz in die
mikrowelle und dann bestreite ich die
oberfläche damit und das reine butter g
also in meinen augen echt flüssiges gold
das geht ich jetzt auf die oberfläche
und es gibt es übrigens auch bei mir im
shop zu kaufen das war ganz wichtig weil
ich weiß es ist ein schwieriges
herzubekommen und habe ich auch kommen
wenn es bei mir im shop gibt dann kann
ich es auch gerne weiter in den videos
zeigen weil ich benutze ist wirklich
sehr sehr gerne
so meine lieben jetzt kommt das in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
und unterhitze in die untere eindruck
leiste ganz wichtig für ca 50 minuten
und in die untere genauer juni
ja weil das sonst wenn ihr das
obendrüber tod das hier oben zu dunkel
wird und wenn ihr das in die untere
eintrittspreise tut dann ist alles
perfekt
[Musik]
solange der ofen vor sich hinarbeitet
machen dir unserem zuckersirup ihr wisst
ja türkische süßspeisen und zuckersirup
das ist wie romeo wie salz und pfeffer
wie gesund sind und wissen auf jeden
fall machen wir jetzt zuckersirup und
das ist ja super einfach also ergibt ja
wirklich nur zucker und wasser in den
topf und lass das 23 minuten lange
köcheln und am ende gehen wir noch ein
spritzer zitronensaft dazu
[Musik]
nach dem backen sieht unser los bei der
jetzt richtig schön goldbraun aus der
man ja gerade den tipp eingeblendet dass
sie das ganze auch vorher schneiden
könnte ich mach das jetzt nachher ist es
ganz einfach vergessen
real life manchmal vergisst man auch
sachen auf jeden fall bis vergessen aber
das macht gar nichts ist es halt nur
einfacher und mit halb ist ein bisschen
schwerer weil es ist ja schon alles sehr
knusprig aber mach mich nicht dass jetzt
einmal in stückchen
[Musik]
so habe ich mir das hier ein stückchen
eingeteilt und den teig ist auch noch
lauwarm ich habe sie zu zehn minuten
abkühlen lassen damit ich die form
anfassen kann ohne mich zu verbrennen
und unser zuckersirup ist auch noch
lauwarm bis kalt da gibt's jetzt
eigentlich verschiedene meinungen musste
zuckerpreis denn oder kalt und dann heiß
drauf gegeben werden da gibt's
verschiedene meinungen bei diesem
rezepte finde ich das relativ egal
einen teil von beiden das auf jeden fall
warm sein in dem fall ist es ja meinen
dass berry und jetzt gebe ich ganz
einfach den zuckersirup drauf
[Musik]
jetzt fehlt nur noch die kühe zeit denn
das bier schmeckt am besten richtig
schön gekühlt aus dem kühlschrank und
ihr könnt danach wenn ihr möchtet noch
mit puderzucker bestäuben und mit
pistazien dekorieren also ich mag das so
ganz gerne für die optik süßen es
wirklich schon genug aber auch nicht so
süß dass man sagt dass er trinkt hier
gerade in zucker sirup das war ja
wirklich nicht viel also eine kleine
menge für meine verhältnisse was mich
viel um ehrlich zu sein ich hoffe dass
euch das rezept gefallen hat wenn ihr
das nachmachen möchte schaut auf jeden
fall hier unten in die infobox da stehen
die genauen mengenangaben und dann freue
ich mich natürlich über eure fotos mit
dem hashtag dieses kitchen auf instagram
und facebook und ich bin schon gespannt
auf euer feedback denn mir schmeckt
super gute vor allem mit dem pudding
dazwischen und ich wünsche euch jetzt
wunderschöne ramadan tage und freue mich
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten video wieder
einschaltet tschüss und ich habe überall
noch zuckersirup an ihm hinten egal
[Musik]
[Applaus]